allez à temps je continue à tourner sur
têt la force
voilà qui on va aller tout droit sortir
de six mois comme en effet tout à
l'heure tu vas te laisse tomber comme
valérie kasteler c'est à peu près le
principal plus spectaculaire est la mère
de jean ses impressionnantes il réitère
la botte pourra pas revenir
c'est un lieu très tendance est au top
comme avant c'est dû à des avancées qui
nous marie jottras sur l'attentât contre
le pape et voilà qu'arrive un moineau
mercantour est adroit dans la mer via un
bouton toujours d'avoir tout donné
voilà tu vois tout avance par la hat a
fait ses débuts en tant que franco ne
tournait un peu à droite anti tv qui la
mettait pas il est tout leur cadre de
vie j'étais présent
de même qu'en face le poète ses pattes
de leurs vecteurs pour rependre a rien
de vrai sera un peu écrasée par
après roanne
tout abattre
franck eux-mêmes n'ont pas tout à
l'heure dans des champs
de ces pierres dépend de la de la misère
d'autrui
quand tu pars
gare de bayonne
enfin
ado france qui fait que tu dragues obama